Here's the thing, I.
I wanna make it known before I start,
like, defending Kim.
I don't like her. I think she's a shitty mom.
I think she did so many things wrong.
I don't think she had her kids best interest at heart almost ever.
Like, just disclaimer,
I'm not a fan of Kim or her style of mothering or parenting.
But we're talking about the trad wife life and where it leads you,
what path it will take you in life.
This woman, regardless of if you agree with her shit,
the agreement was, I'm gonna stay home and take care of the kids,
the farm, do the homeschooling, everything.
You, Barry,
are gonna work and financially support the family.
And that is how we are all gonna share it.
And in the end. Exactly.
She's living on a fucking boat,
taking showers in a public fucking bathroom.
If it weren't for her fucking boyfriend,
where the fuck would this bitch be?
That's my point exactly. When you get set up,
when you set yourself up to be in the tried wife life,
when it ends, you're gonna end up homeless with nothing,
dependent on other people still,
and they're not your husband.
So, you know,
good luck finding somebody to really fully support you.
And then they're gonna hold your kids captive and they're gonna say,
well, what kind of mother could you be?
How are you gonna be able to support your kids?
Look at you. You're living on a boat.
You're living here. You're living on someone's couch.
How can you take care of your kids?
And it's gonna backfire in your face.
You know, I just think that's such a shitty position to take
and not look at it and say, wow,
why is she on a boat?
What did she have in her own name that she could put down for a house
or put down to have her own place to live?
Everything is tied up because everything was marital property.
Everything were marital assets and marital debt.
And now what's happening? Barry's trying to take her for everything,
as if she didn't give all that she had for those 24 years.
Again, I'm not defending her.
I don't think she's a good mom.
I think she was giving what she had to give.
I don't think she's well in the head.
I think she's got a lot of fucking issues,
but. Exactly.
You're gonna spend your whole life
giving everything you have to these people, saying,
it's okay, I know they're gonna take care of me,
I know I'm gonna be okay. I have all my faith and trust in these people.
And in the end, you're the one left having to fend for yourself,
whatever that means. In her situation,
it's living on a fucking broken boat,
using public bathrooms and charcoal grills.
And hopefully her boyfriend can help her out sometime.
So she's still stuck, you know,
it's the Chad, Wife,
life is really only benefits the man.
And if you're the woman in the situation,
you are setting yourself up for potentially a really fucking shitty,
you know, elder years,
older years, whatever.